I was able to spend a night in such a spooky place.If
by some chance there really was a ghost, I'd
say to Claire-sama, please.What is this?This is called chocolate.It's a chocolate cake that Claire-sama also loves.
Actually,
speaking of chocolate, it's a
state-of-the-art sweet released by the high-class restaurant Blume.Okay,
well, don't worry about the details, just
try it.There's nothing that
suits my taste that is
n't from Blume's class.It's
delicious chocolate.  A flavorful cake.
Chocolate overflowing from the inside. I can't
get enough of it. Haemin. Which pastry chef did
you make this cake? You made it! Actually,
I've been working hard on developing recipes lately.
When did you have time to spend time with me? A
suspicious
figure suddenly appeared. The ghost in the galley turned out to be you.
Yes, that's correct. Well, I knew it from the beginning.
It's Mochi's Ron.  That's why I
prepared something like this. Before I knew it, there was only
one pair left. Let's sleep together. I
suddenly felt like an idiot. I'll eat the
cake and then go home. Yeah, aren't you going to stay the night?
No, it's not a ghost anymore.The
commotion has been resolved, so we
really don't know the identity of the mysterious hand.Hey, just
relax.I won't be fooled anymore.It's
not a lie.I'll let you go home first.
Claire-sama
[Music] Oh, I'm
here,
Leleo-ah
Lele, I've
followed you too, ah-ah-ah-ah-ha-ha-ha, I
mean, wet handprints are a makeover boom, right? I'm
heading home. Storm ah-ah, Claire-
sama.